dix mille amateurs de golf se sont
rendus ce week end à mantes-la-jolie la
ville a accueilli du 12 au 14 avril un
grand salon sur la petite balle blanche
une grande première pour la commune et
le département des yvelines qui compte
26 golf de 18 trous sur son territoire
c'est un rendez vous de passionnés c'est
un salon communautaire autour de la
passion golfique c'est à dire que le but
de l'événement c'est d'immerger les
passionnés dans leur secteur de passion
avec toutes les composantes de la
culture golfique avec du club avec du
chaussant de la balle
des éléments techniques comme été les
maîtres ou les montres connectés qui
permet de géolocaliser connaître la
distance jusqu'au drapeau
au total une centaine d'exposants
étaient présents pendant les trois jours
du salon pour séduire encore plus les
golfeurs les organisateurs ont également
mis en place un practice de 120 mètres
en plein air pour tester le matériel
dans des conditions réelles
c'est un plus parce que les joueurs
veulent essayer les clubs en plein air
ils veulent voir la balle volée ils
veulent voir les performances avec
chaque marque donc c'est vrai que c'est
vraiment très très important rythme là
ça sauve pas mal donc on peut se rendre
vraiment compte des trajectoires des
balles et
comment dire des fsi un signe en effet
s'est vraiment amplifié par part
justement le vent une deuxième édition
est déjà programmée pour l'année
prochaine à la mi avril l'objectif sera
d'attirer encore plus de golfeurs et
notamment des débutants